[Music]
let's go to atlanta
uh where we started off franklin is
joining us there franklin how can we
help
i'm doing well hope you guys are too um
john honor to talk to you you always
give sage advice and uh dig a little bit
deeper and hit the nail on the head
uh so just thank you thank you you guys
can help me out today so what's up
um so my grandparents uh have it's
been their intention ever since i was
born to give me their house
that they have lived in uh they actually
built it
could have been on home and gardens done
a lot of acreage um
very beautiful but my grandfather has
since passed my grandmother is now eight
nine and it's in a lot of disrepair um
and furthermore that there's no use for
me to have this house it's you know an
hour away from where me my wife and my
family are currently living and it's
the amount of upkeep it would require as
almost a full-time job so there's just
no way i can keep it
uh but my grandma always tells me you
know now that she's getting at the end
of her life that's her
you know intent is to give me this house
i'm in the will to do what she actually
wants to go ahead and title it to me now
but i don't have it in my heart really
to uh
tell her that you know i would not plan
on keeping this house my intent would be
to
to sell it unfortunately just because i
wanted to be a blessing and not a burden
um so kind of having some issues dealing
with that
what is it a
why can't you just take the house and
then when it comes time for you to make
decisions that are right for you and
your family at a later time
um you can make those decisions then
i can certainly do that and i think um i
guess my issue comes down to
you know she always asks me what would i
do with the house you know when it is
mine and i kind of you know shrugged my
shoulders you know i'm not really sure
yet
have to make a decision about that later
but in my heart i know we would sell it
so i just feel bad
i guess i don't say leading her on um
but i kind of just feel bad about you
know telling her or even just doing that
really i think there's a lot of equity
issues too
where i've been kind of the golden child
of the family yep
there's a lot of other grandkids you
know there it is that's what i was
getting at this has nothing to do with
that house dude you don't want to be
that kid
right yeah i mean that's that's
definitely part of it i think
the bigger part really is i don't want
to let her down and i feel like i would
be letting both you know my late
grandfather and her down
by selling the property
i i disagree with that um it may be a
conversation you have with the rest of
your family
you're a grown-up you can do what you
want to with a gift that somebody gives
you
if you if it's a family home and it's a
family estate then clearly if you're
going to sell it then
you could um sell it for a dollar to
your cousin
right or to you could create a truck
there's a hundred different things you
could do
with it um it's it sounds like you're
making it a bigger ethical deal than
than it needs to be and if you think it
needs to stay in the family but you
don't want it
if you don't want to quote unquote
disappoint somebody that gave you a gift
then do what you want to do with it but
i don't see any
reason why you need to tell your grandma
um hey i'm not taking this gift
like she's eight wait how old is she 86.
89 i mean i don't know it's it's gonna
be a gift to her to let her take
take the gift what do you think ken um i
don't disagree with what you're saying
john
but i would challenge you franklin if
you don't want the house
for the reasons that you don't want the
house it's not like her coming to your
birthday party when you're 11 and giving
your birthday present you're going i
don't want a birthday present from me i
think that's sting pretty hard
i think if you explain to her why you
don't want the house but you're honored
you're you're you're you're feeling all
the feelings and you say
grandma i don't want the house but i
want to hurt you i think it's simple you
got to put your big boy pants on and i
think there's a way to do that
um but i don't disagree with what john
said either i think you got to get over
either way you're going to have to get
over disappointing
somebody here i think that's the issue
either i'm disappointed or i'm worried
about criticism from my siblings or
whoever else uncle larry or the cousins
uh or i'm worried about grandma being
disappointed at some point
john i'm not gonna make a major life
decision that i don't believe i should
do
just because it might disappoint
somebody so i'm going to be a little bit
tougher and go
put your big boy pants on franklin and
tell grandma the truth i think she can
handle it but be loving yeah
very respectful in the process that's
what i do and i'd take the house
and we'll figure it out later that's why
i said i don't disagree but if he's
worried about his other stuff somebody's
got to make the decision